[Music]
my name's anna davis and i'm the
principal investigator of sharecity and
professor of geography environment
society at trinity college dublin in
ireland
so i've been working on matters of
sustainable consumption now for more
than a decade
and it's very clear that we have an
unsustainable food system
the chesty food project was really
established
to try and look at new ways of making
our food system more sustainable
we know that urban food sharing takes
place around the globe
so we really don't know what social
environmental and economic impact it has
the four phases of share sea include
mapping creating a database this is the
first international database
conducted of all of the urban food show
across 100
cities and the second phase was looking
at in-depth ethnography so working with
food sharing initiatives all around the
globe
then we worked with those initiatives to
co-design a sustainability impact
assessment tool called share it
and the final phase of shasta is
examining the future
of urban food sharing so the chesty
project had a multi-faceted social and
online media
strategy and this was important because
as the
food sharing initiatives are often
invisible we really needed to know from
the grassroots
what was going on and so we crowdsourced
our database
of 100 cities looking for food sharing
initiatives
we were able to work with sharing
networks internationally
to be able to establish the landscape
really of urban food sharing
yeah so i think the first thing i would
say to applicants is to
really build in time to do
communications and take it seriously but
also enjoy the ride you will experience
things you've never experienced before
but this will bring
untold benefits to your research another
thing to remember is that be prepared to
make mistakes
you're learning things which are not
necessarily in your professional toolbox
and but i've certainly learnt a lot by
working with media professionals
both online and social
you